se promener au jardin des tuileries à ce
moment là c'est prémédité de sa part il
savait qu'il allait tomber sur des gens
qui ne l'aiment pas parce que de toute
façon le président qu'on a en ce moment
a plus de chance de tomber sur des gens
qui ne l'aiment pas plutôt que le
contraire donc il savait pertinemment
qu'il y avait eu une manif
juste avant il savait qu'il allait
rencontrer des gens des opposants on va
dire pour pas dire plus
c'est tombé sur moi ils vont petit
groupe serait plus tomber sur n'importe
quel autre groupe mais c'est pas une
preuve de courage de sa part d'avoir
d'être revenu sur ses pas il est entouré
par services de sécurité absolument
énorme
renforcé par paru quelques agents de
sécurité privés nous on n'est pas très
nombreux à ce moment là il ne risque
rien véritablement si ce n'est une
confrontation verbale comme c'est ce qui
s'est passé derrière mais je regrette et
je m'en suis excusé à plusieurs reprises
de ne pas avoir été le meilleur sur coup
love voilà parce que j'ai fait valoir
je mets parler de mon envie de ne plus
voir la brave dans les manifs parce que
j'en sortais une heure avant et que l'on
s'était encore pris plein de trucs dans
la vue du gaz des charges des sociétés
cela est que ce genre de choses je ne
supporte plus des bois dans les manifs
pour moi et pour tous les manifestants
donc c'est pour ça que j'ai abordé tout
de suite ce sujet avec lui je lui dis
supprimer la brave arrêté avec la brave
parce que c'est provocateur
ils sont quand ils sont là ça forcément
ça par an souvent en cacahuète et si je
lui dis d'ailleurs si vous voulez que ça
commence si vous voulez que ça aille
mieux ça veut pas dire que tout soit
réglé
je lui dis si vous voulez que ça aille
mieux déjà un peu commencé par supprimer
sa voix l'a ensuite les autres sujets
que j'aborde j'essaye de faire au mieux
mais je suis loin d'être parfait sur ce
coup là c'est clair c'est clair